one of my favorite black owned  businesses is a company called trap yoga  bay which is run by a woman called  britney floyd mayo and she is a young  black queer single mother and she has  started this incredible and inclusive  yoga movement where you know the yoga  space is something that we predominantly  associate  for reasons i cannot understand with  thin  white women mostly and she has  diversified it and democratized it and  she uses trap music to make it  unpretentious and fun and free and so it  feels like you're going to the club and  yet getting this great meditative  workout and so she makes sure that there  are women of all different racial  backgrounds of all different sizes who  will cut her classes feeling amazing and  there need to be more and more people  like her within the yoga space but  within every space